aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
perdí las piernas por primera vez el 22
de enero del 2015 en un accidente
automovilístico
la segunda vez fue el verano pasado me
desperté y no les encontraba
con aquellas
[Aplausos]
con aquellas primeras piernas que
quedaron en el accidente
practicaba deportes y fútbol
especialmente desde que tengo 4 o 5 años
de edad
decidí retirarme del fútbol competitivo
a los 37 por razones que son obvias para
todos tengo muchas ganas
lo que no me imaginaba
es que el deporte y ese fútbol amateur
algún día me salvaría en la vida y es la
explicación a la que llegan los médicos
de que haya sobrevivido a perder casi 4
litros de sangre en aquel accidente
el deporte vuelve a aparecer en mi vida
dos meses después en un centro de
rehabilitación donde además de preparar
mis piernas para recibir las primeras
prótesis
aprovechado para entrenar el resto del
cuerpo para poder usarlas de la mejor
manera
pero también para alejarme cada día más
de esa silla de ruedas que me acompaña
durante casi siete meses en esos siete
meses tenía objetivos muy cotidianos
imagínense ustedes por un instante
sentados como están ahora
intentar lavarse la cara
yo quería estar parado para eso
para poder lavarme los dientes quería
estar parado para poder afeitarme al
frente de un espejo o simplemente para
encontrar esos chocolates que me
escondían en la parte alta de la
heladera
llegaron esas primeras prótesis y los
kinesiólogos me advirtieron que iba a
ser un proceso largo que primero usaría
un andador después bastones y que quizás
después de un mes podría caminar de
manera independiente
pero era tanta la ansiedad que sentía y
tan buena la preparación previa
que cuando me pare por primera vez sobre
las prótesis simplemente tire el andador
hacia un costado y salí caminando con
mucha naturalidad
con tanta suerte de que me aparece una
pelota en el gimnasio de la ortopedia y
empiezo a patear la como si acá no
hubiera pasado nada
hasta que al día siguiente me la
escondieron porque le había pegado
pelotas solo espejo a los pacientes que
andaban por ahí
a penas de esos primeros pasos en una
entrevista televisiva me animé a contar
que soñaba
con volver a andar en bicicleta con
volver a jugar al fútbol
y con volver a correr
me escucha gastón
un amigo que es corredor ironman y al
día siguiente me busca en una bicicleta
para intentar andar
empezamos a pedalear el ciclismo es un
gran deporte pero además en mi condición
me genera una sensación de libertad y de
desplazamiento de velocidad pero además
y sobre todo al no tener impacto en el
piso no me genera ningún dolor
al final de ese día que habíamos ido a
probar habíamos volado
perdón la sensación era esa en realidad
habíamos pedaleado más de 10 kilómetros
germán de la fundación empate una
escuelita de fútbol gratuita para niños
con síndrome de dawn me habla y me dice
pablo necesitamos un arquero para el
partido a beneficio de fin de año se
imaginarán que mi respuesta además de
obvia fue muy rápida y ahí estuve llegó
el día
entrar de nuevo a la cancha después de
todo lo que había pasado medias de
fútbol pantalón de fútbol la remera de
la fundación y unos guantes de arqueros
espectaculares
empezó a rodar la pelota y les puedo
asegurar aunque parezca luego que ese
día sentí que me temblaban las piernas y
el broche de oro fue el partido de
exhibición que hicieron los alumnos de
la escuelita nos llenó el alma a todos
y de la mano de gustavo
dueño de una ortopedia de la ciudad de
córdoba cumplimos el tercer sueño
volver a correr gustavo tenía las
prótesis deportivas que lo harían
posible y yo unas ganas tremendas de
salir a probarlas después de algunos
ensayos en el gimnasio de la ortopedia
en el que me estrellé con todas las
paredes posibles decidimos ir a una
pista de atletismo
nuestra meta era ver si podíamos dar la
vuelta completa al óvalo de 400 metros
empecé a correr la adrenalina que sentía
hizo desaparecer no solo mis miedos sino
también cualquier molestia o cualquier
dolor que podría haber sentido
y sentí quizás como nunca antes
ese viento en la cara que sentimos
cuando corremos
que además le aseguró que servía para
sacarme las lágrimas
de la felicidad que tenía por volver a
correr nuevamente
al final de ese día de cinco vueltas a
esa pista algo tan fácil y hasta
rutinario antes del accidente se había
convertido en un desafío muy importante
y convirtió ese día en uno de los más
felices de mi vida
a esta altura ya había aprendido como
viralizar algunas de estas novedades era
bastante simple
le mandaba una foto o un vídeo a mi mamá
y le pedía que no se lo muestre a nadie
imposible a las dos horas me estaban
invitando a participar de una carrera la
primera carrera de 3 km
no la primera carrera después del
accidente la primera carrera de mi vida
a los 40 años de edad
y necesitaba estar motivado
cuando pienso en las motivaciones la
imagino de diferentes maneras
esa próxima carrera una competencia de
ciclismo
un partido de tenis la posibilidad
escalar una montaña funcionan para mí
como un gran motor
y ese motor me hace levantar todas las
mañanas antes de las 6 y mientras me
preparo para enfrentar mi jornada
laboral como abogado
estoy pensando no sólo si termine de
redactar aquel contrato sino si la
bicicleta está inflada o si mis prótesis
de correr están bien alineadas para
entrenar durante la tarde
ese motor me hizo entrenar muy duro
para esa primera carrera
y para mi ultimo duatlón corriendo 7
kilómetros y medio y 20 en bicicleta
y también para uno de los retos más
trascendentes intentar hacer cumbre en
el aconcagua que es la montaña más alta
de américa
también pienso en la motivación como el
combustible que ese motor necesita
y son las personas son ustedes
personalmente por teléfono oa través de
la magia de las redes sociales
siento la alegría y la felicidad que le
provoca a los demás cada avance en mi
recuperación
el impacto positivo de cada nuevo
desafío que se presenta y que lo llevo
adelante
ese combustible que nos llena el alma y
el corazón de energías
al que simplemente llamo el combustible
humano
pero para que ese combustible humano se
vuelva más puro y más potente
existe la posibilidad que se me presenta
a diario de poder ayudar a los demás
cómo ir al hospital de niños
a visitar a malena a pedido de su mamá
una adolescente de 16 años a quien
acababan de amputarle una pierna a causa
de un tumor
su familia tenía mucha incertidumbre
sobre cómo sería su futuro con una
piernita menos
pero ella tenía una preocupación mucho
más concreta
quería saber si podría volver a patinar
algo que había hecho siempre y era su
pasión
mientras despertaba de la cirugía me
había entrar a la habitación caminando
con normalidad con mis pantalones cortos
primero impacto positivo me siento a su
lado le cuento mi experiencia de
aquellos días y empiezo a mostrarlo en
mi teléfono
fotos y vídeos en los que estoy jugando
al fútbol
nadando andando en bicicleta jugando al
tenis corriendo subiendo escaleras y
hasta subiendo montañas
y por esas cosas mágicas de la vida en
el teléfono aparece una foto que había
tomado poquitos días antes en la que
estoy subido a unos patines tipos
rollers les puedo asegurar que todos ahí
sentimos que el mundo se quedaba en
pausa
y la mirada de mahle brillar como un sol
una sonrisa le cubría toda su cara y los
rostros de la familia que nos rodeaba a
cambio definitivamente
fui a llevarle un consejo a contarle mi
experiencia a tranquilizarla y me llevé
un apretado abrazo a mi alma
y la promesa de que pronto patín
haríamos juntos
además de mi familia y de los que me
aguantan tienen la suerte aguantarme
todos los días
hay una gran estación donde sé que puedo
cargar combustible y es mi grupo de
what's up con otros amputados que se
llama los imparables
se imaginarán porque el nombre
con los imparables nos motivamos a
mostrar las aventuras en las cuales
estamos incursionando nos alentamos pero
también lo usamos para coordinar la
posibilidad de entrenar juntos
participar en alguna carrera
o simplemente comer algo rico
sobre todo cuando viene alejandro
un joven amputado que acaba de recorrer
casi 3000 kilómetros en bicicleta desde
el sur de córdoba hasta ushuaia y quien
es para nosotros una gran motivación
pero en realidad lo invitamos porque
fabrica cerveza artesanal
aprendí
que solo no habría llegado tan lejos
haber contado mi sueño en aquella
entrevista hizo que apareciera la
bicicleta el partido de fútbol y las
prótesis para correr se amplió mi
círculo humano virtuoso a las personas
que me acompañaron siempre encontré
otras de las cuales me enorgullezco me
encontré inmerso en una comunidad que me
alienta y me empuja a día a día a
alcanzar todas mis metas
hace dos años atrás mis objetivos eran
pararme para lavarme los dientes hoy
estoy entrenando para competir en
triatlón para un campeonato de tenis
para escalar una montaña
encontré motores
los alimente con el mejor de los
combustibles
y me puse de nuevo de pie ante la vida
para enfrentar mis dificultades pero
también y sobre todo
para hacer frente con convicción y con
alegría a todos mis proyectos
ya no tengo dudas
los límites están en nuestra imaginación
no hay más excusas
el accidente marcó mi vida eso es obvio
pero lo que realmente me volvió
imparable es esta nueva y sana costumbre
de soñar con los ojos abiertos y en voz
alta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah